Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my spider-man 3 daredevil
video there was a couple clips that
posted this week a lot of you were
asking me because Charlie Cox had been
talking about spider-man 3 this is a
bunch of Marvel phase 4 stuff that he
talks about so we'll break it all down
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing an Amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite daredevil moment on the
video so just going down the list
starting with number 5 Charlie Cox
himself did a daredevil rewatch party
with the comic book people and during
that they talked a lot about him coming
into the MCU properly during Marvel
phase 4 and future projects and about
him being in spider-man 3 because of all
the recent reports that daredevil might
be featured somehow during spider-man 3
Kevin Smith and a lot of other people
were reporting that there was supposed
to be a lawyer at some point during
spider-man 3 that would help him clear
his name
because Mysterio framed him for his
death and outed his identity so in
addition to any sinister six villains
like Kraven that they introduced during
the movie there are a couple problems
that spider-man can't punch in the face
like he has a bunch of legal problems
that he'll need some help with this is
that clip of Charlie Cox talking about
spider-man 3 in Marvel phase 4.
Yes I didn't,  I hadn't heard those rumors.
I mean it's certainly not my I'm certainly
not involved in any of that. If that's true
it's not with me it's with another is
with another actor I mean do you want to
appear with spider-man right I love to
I'm very grateful I had a great time I
had a great run of it I couldn't be
happier I'm so grateful I got to play
that character for as long as I did but
you know of course I would love to keep
going and you know love to be involved
with as much of you know I love it as a
fan of the Marvel movies I love the
little stuff that they do where you can
they pop up here and there and that was
the one thing because we were on Netflix
we weren't really able to do as much I
think for kind of legal reasons I don't
know why but I think that was the reason. So, but
I I loved the idea of you know like
Jessica and you know
and Matt showing up in the
background or you know Matt as just
as a lawyer advising Peter Parker or
whatever it is you know would be really
really cool
So 4 during that clip he's either a
very good liar most superheroes are or
Marvel just really hasn't contacted him
about spider-man 3 or future MCU
projects yet Marvel also recently
auctioned all the props in the costumes
off from daredevil and the other Marvel
Netflix series so even if they do bring
him back as daredevil and Marvel phase 4
it would have to be a totally different
costume which I think everyone is fine
with gerd elbows weren't a couple iconic
costumes in the comics there's even the
clip at the beginning of this that I put
there with him putting his mask on and
sipping his coffee like it's no big deal
just chilling out during quarantine the
other really interesting thing that he
mentions during that is there was some
weird legal issue preventing the Netflix
characters from crossing over into the
MCU during infinity war and Avengers
endgame the Russo said that they D
consider the Marvel Netflix characters
so maybe at some point they were going to
jump over it whatever that hurdle was
but it sounds like there were bigger
legal problems behind that than people
originally believed originally people
just assumed that the movie people
didn't care about the Netflix characters
but turns out that's not the case there
was actually some real legal issues with
it he says a couple things about the MCU
and Marvel phase four during that clip
but let's assume for a hot minute that
he's not lying and they really have not
called him yet remember the spider-man 3
won't even go into production till way
later this year and even if daredevil
does show up during spider-man 3 based
on what people are reporting about the
movie it sounds like it would be a
relatively minor role in movies that big
only cast actors for roles right before
they need them to film a scene
originally spider-man 3 was going to film
from July to October just like they did
for spider-man far from home and
spider-man Home Coming before that Sony
and Marvel just confirmed that they
delayed the movie to November next year
so spider-man 3 won't be coming out to
the end of next year if you didn't know
that means they might not start filming
the movie till November this year even
though that's beyond the 2-year
cooling-off period for daredevil there's
that standard cooling-off period for the
Marvel Netflix characters it's a little
bit different because the cooling-off
period starts when each series ends so
I'll explain that in a second too
because then everybody's wondering when
is Punisher going to come back what are
they going to do with the Luke Cage
character what are they going to
with iron fist if they're going to recast
that character so three there was a
recent report about some of the other
Marvel Netflix characters recently
including Punisher a lot of people it
turns out had falsely assumed that
Marvel was free and clear to use the
Punisher character anytime they wanted
because of the way the contract with
Netflix worked turns out that's not the
case and Punisher is still subject to a
two-year cooling-off period like all the
other Marvel Netflix characters even if
you weren't a big fan of that series I
feel like he was amazing as The Punisher
just like Charlie Cox was amazing as
daredevil but while the cooling-off
period for daredevil might be up in time
for him to be in spider-man 3 Marvel
can't even think about using the
Punisher character till next spring so
I'll talk about where Punisher might
show up next in the MCU
but like Luke Cage and iron fist their
series ended a little bit sooner they're
ready to be used again in September this
year Jessica Jones isn't going to be free
until next summer though as of right now
though all the Marvel Netflix actors
have said that they have not been called
about future MCU projects some of them
might be lying because I'm sure there's
some people inside Marvel Studios that
want to put those characters in projects
that they're doing for Disney Plus like
a lot of you have asked about them
recasting a version of iron fist and
putting him in the shang-chi movies if
they do sequels which they probably will
I think a slightly different version of
iron fist would work great inside the
shang-chi franchise or they could put
them on the moon night series with other
street-level heroes like daredevil would
also work great on a moon night series
even though I feel like the big ticket
sell is putting them in a big spider-man
movie until Marvel does its thunderbolts
Disney Plus Series moon night is going to
be the most hardcore Disney Plus series
that they have just because of the tone
of the character they haven't confirmed
who their Moon Knight is going to be but
they were originally going to start filming
later this year that might not start
till next year now because of the virus
delays but it sounds like they're
planning on releasing the Moon Knight
series sometime during 2022 number two
the other big thing Charlie Cox talks
about during that clip is the implies
Marvel might recast daredevil and it
won't be him coming back into the MCU
because Kevin Feige is a big fan of the
daredevil character he's talked about
wanting to do things with daredevil but
because of the Netflix contract that
hasn't been possible I think fans would
be pissed if they recast though and if
you recast Charlie Cox it would imply
that they probably wind up recasting
everybody in Vincent
Frio was an amazing version of the
kingpin people would ask him all the
time season to season do you want to
cross over with spider-man and of course
he would say things like yes but I don't
think that's ever going to happen that
was a couple of years ago and that was
before Sony started developing a bunch
of spider-man TV projects I just did a
video about how some of those might wind
up on Disney Plus he would be perfect in
a Disney Plus spider-man series a lot of
you also wondered about what was going
on with daredevil season 3 because they
did have a really cool x-men Wolverine
Easter egg at the end if you're not a
big comic book reader or you're not
familiar with the bullseye back story in
the comics he gets his ass handed to him
breaks his spine then gets it replaced
with an adamantium one the same way that
Wolverine had adamantium coated all over
his skeleton bullseye comes back with
the adamantium spine that much stronger
but also as a result of his surgery he
can no longer feel pain he winds up
coming back with a vengeance and they
did that at the end of daredevil season
3 that was sort of their post-credit
scene
bullseye getting his adamantium spine
so we have a lot of Marvel phase 4 x-men
Easter eggs that are coming up Marvel
phase 5 genuine x-men characters showing
up even if they wind up recasting some
of the Marvel Netflix characters what
they might do is they might take the
Star Wars approach in the expanded
universe there was an expanded universe
full of a bunch of characters inside
books games all kinds of stuff the
Disney just said this isn't canon
anymore and only the movies and some of
the TV shows are Canon now but every
once in a while they'll pick and choose
things from the expanded universe and
bring them back into mainstream Canon
Marvel might take that approach with
some of the Marvel Netflix characters
when they reintroduce them into the MCU
but everyone let me know in the comments
if they do wind up recasting some of the
Marvel Netflix characters which ones
would you want them to recast I feel
like everybody be ok at them recasting
iron fist and as long as they keep
Charlie Cox's daredevil Jon Bernthal is
the Punisher in Mike Colter is Luke Cage
I feel like people will probably be okay
with them recasting some of the other
characters but if you're going to do
Charlie Cox's daredevil then you would
probably have to do Eldon Henson's
version of foggy Nelson too it'd be weird
to have his daredevil with a different
foggy but fun Easter Egg if you guys
haven't seen the Ben Affleck daredevil
in a long time it wasn't a great movie
but happy Hogan himself Jon Favreau
actually played foggy Nelson during that
movie so it's just funny to see actors
show up in different Marvel projects
over the years even though Fox wound up
making that movie so it doesn't really
have any ties to modern-day MCU stuff
Listen to this. Eye witness's say that
Quesada was singled out by the demonic vigilante
known as the Daredevil.
if we get any more news
about Spider Man and new versions of
daredevil of course I'll do a video
about it congratulations Kyle Kaiser
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details everyone click here for
that Avengers infinity saga deleted
scene of Doctor Strange becoming Iron
Man becoming the iron mage and click
here for my venom 2 trailer Easter eggs
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!